(Geflüstert) Zwei Stück.
- Da auch noch eines.
Dort kamen auch noch welche durch.
Es gab eine Zeit,
wenn ich da im Herbst
tatsächlich an einer Fortbildung war
und man meinen Patienten sagte,
ich sei nicht da, hiess es gleich:
"Ich weiss schon,
dass er auf der Jagd ist."
Irgendwann ist es Zeit, loszulassen.
Irgendwann fängt etwas Neues an.
Dies sind vier Geschichten
rund um Menschen,
die sich ans Abenteuer Nachfolge
wagen.
Einer von ihnen
ist Hausarzt Martin Sigg.
Das sind
sehr wichtige Bestandteile.
Ruhe und Zeit.
Und ... einfach mal zu sein,
ohne immer denken zu müssen.
Und sich im Beruf die Konsequenzen
überlegen, wie es weitergehen muss.
Es ist manchmal
einfach so ein Innehalten.
Das ist sehr schön, finde ich.
* Schuss *
Der kam von da hinten.
* Surren eines Handys *
Ja?
(Aus dem Telefon) Juhu!
- Was hast du geschossen?
Ehrlich?
Ja, ja, dann kommen wir zu dir.
Edi habe jetzt auch
einen geschossen.
Martin Sigg
ist regelmässig mit Freunden
auf der Jagd im Tirol unterwegs.
Vor gut zehn Jahren wäre er
beinahe in ein Burnout geraten.
Seither arbeitet er
nur noch an vier Tagen die Woche
und achtet auf Ausgleich.
Hier stand er und so fiel er hin,
fertig. Tot.
Die Jagd ist für Martin Sigg
eine Passion,
die ihn ein Leben lang begleitet.
Weidmännisch perfekt.
Ich bin mit der Jagd
als natürlichem Ereignis,
das zum Leben gehört, aufgewachsen.
Ausserdem
ist mein Jagdhintergrund auch,
dass sowohl mein Vater als auch
mein Bruder jagten bzw. jagen.
Darum war das für mich
das Natürlichste auf der Welt.
Ich hatte eher Mühe damit,
zu verstehen,
dass jemand die Jagd
nicht verstehen kann
und sie
als etwas Wesensfremdes ansieht.
Auch deine Mutter war ...
Ja, meine Mutter
hat im Kanton Nidwalden
als Erste die Jagdprüfung gemacht.
Sie hat zwar nie ein Tier geschossen
und wollte das auch nicht,
aber die Jagdprüfung
wollte sie machen,
und sie kam immer mit zur Jagd.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Sehr gut.
- Vielen Dank.
Er hat ihn
am richtigen Ort geschossen.
Mhm. Er hat
einen schönen Brunftfleck.
Dieser schwarze Brunftfleck.
Aline Berger ist die neue Pfarrerin
von Ostermundigen.
Es ist ihre erste Stelle.
Heute hat sie
ihren ersten Gottesdienst.
Gut. Wie immer. Ja.
Nein. Jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht wenn die Musik
dann aufhört und ich weiss,
dass ich nun aufstehen
und als Erste etwas sagen muss.
Dann vielleicht.
Aber jetzt noch nicht.
* Dunkle Bassklänge,
fröhliches Stimmengewirr *
Ursina.
Guten Tag.
- Die Frau Pfarrer.
Ich freue mich, dass Sie bei
meinem ersten Gottesdienst da sind.
Wir freuen uns auch sehr.
Wir sind gespannt.
Schön.
Gut, dann lasse ich Sie wieder üben.
- Genau.
Super.
Während 27 Jahren wirkte
Pfarrer Christen in der Gemeinde.
Aline ist bewusst,
dass sie, die Neue,
heute besonders kritisch
beobachtet wird.
Einigen ist noch wichtig,
dass man anständig gekleidet ist.
Ja, und ...
Dann merken sie vielleicht gar
nicht, dass ich auch Neues sage,
wenn ich brav gekleidet bin.
Das ist mein Trick.
Seit 1969 haben sich alle,
die hier einmal gepredigt haben,
hier eingeschrieben.
Genesis, Kapitel 2,
Verse 4-8 und 18-25.
Ich beginne
eben extra bei Adam und Eva.
Genau, so ist es.
Ihr Vorgänger Peter Christen
ist frisch pensioniert.
Auf jeden Fall fragte sie mich:
"Du, Peschä, wer kommt denn da?"
"Kommt denn da
einfach so das Stammpublikum?"
"V.a. die älteren,
frommen Menschen?"
Da sagte ich: "Nein.
Heute kommt Krethi und Plethi,
denn die wollen dich kennenlernen
und sehen, wie du funktionierst."
Ich bin wahnsinnig gespannt
und freue mich sehr.
Denn ich habe sie jetzt
etwas kennengelernt,
habe ihr den Computer
und das Telefon erklärt
und alle nötigen Applikationen
etwas nähergebracht.
Ich erlebte sie als sehr dezidierte,
klare und fröhliche Frau.
Mir hat gefallen,
wie sie sich gibt.
Darum bin ich sehr gespannt,
wie sie das jetzt
in die Predigten und die Gestaltung
der Gottesdienste einbringt.
Da bin ich wirklich total gespannt
und freue mich.
Ich freue mich.
Wir müssen früh da sein,
damit ich noch Hallo sagen kann.
Ja.
* Sanfte, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Wir stossen mit Links an.
Nach drei Tagen Jagd und Geselligkeit
unter Freunden kommt am Schlussapéro
auch Martin Siggs Nachfolgersuche
zur Sprache.
Die letzten Interessenten
haben nämlich wieder abgesagt.
Tja,
dann wird er halt weiter arbeiten.
Er wird niemanden finden
für seine Praxis.
Wie lange suchst du jetzt schon
nach Nachfolgern?
Drei, vier Jahre.
Ernsthaft. Niemand ist mehr bereit,
ein solches Engagement einzugehen.
Die wollen das weder finanziell
noch zeitlich.
Sie wollen nur noch von 8 bis 17 Uhr
arbeiten, Samstag, Sonntag frei.
Die Notfälle
überlassen sie den Spitälern.
Aber das ist auch irgendwo das Ende
des frei praktizierenden Arztes,
wenn man es so macht.
Ich sehe die Chancen bei 50/50,
dass das klappen wird.
Ich habe es schon einmal probiert,
und der erste Interessent
hat sich dann verabschiedet
und sich verständlicherweise
für ein Projekt entschieden,
das näher an seinem Wohnort ist.
Jetzt werden wir sehen, was sich
in den nächsten Wochen ergibt.
Ich habe noch einen Interessenten,
der es sich überlegt.
Super. Dann ist das die Einweihung
des neuen Dachs, oder wie?
Nicht nur Peter Christen
will sich von der ersten Predigt
seiner Nachfolgerin Aline
überraschen lassen.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, willkommen.
- Willkommen.
Guten Morgen, Frau Berger.
- Guten Morgen, willkommen.
Ich versuche, mir die Namen
zu merken, aber ... Guten Morgen.
Es kommen doch einige.
Da bin ich froh.
Ich war gespannt,
ob denn da doch einige kommen.
Salut. Herzlich willkommen.
Hallo, Peter. Willkommen.
Schön, dass du auch kommst.
Ich setze mich dort rüber.
- Ist gut.
Liebe Gemeinde.
Ich sagte, ich wolle heute
bei Adam und Eva anfangen.
Das stimmt fast.
Ich möchte eigentlich
beim einsamen Erdling anfangen.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt denken:
"Für so eine Märchenstunde bin ich
heute morgen nicht aufgestanden",
dann kann ich Sie beruhigen.
Denn diese Geschichte
steht in der Bibel.
Sogar im 1. Buch Mose.
Das traditionelle Missverständnis
dieser Geschichte geht etwa so:
Vor langer, langer Zeit hat der
Herrgott den Herrn Adam geschaffen
und hat ihn in einen
schönen Paradiesgarten gesetzt.
Dort war Adam alleine,
der arme Tropf.
Gott hatte Erbarmen mit ihm und
wollte ihm eine Hilfe schaffen.
So etwas wie eine tüchtige Hausfrau,
die für diesen Herrn der Schöpfung
kocht, putzt und Hemden bügelt.
Der Mann wurde also
ganz klar zuerst erschaffen
und Eva und auch alle anderen Frauen
danach.
Was für eine
schreckliche Geschichte.
Es war eine meiner schönsten Stunden
im Theologiestudium,
als meine Professorin
für das Alte Testament erklärte,
dass das eigentlich ganz anders
zu verstehen ist mit Adam und Eva.
Hier im tiefen Emmental,
in Röthenbach,
konnte Familie Wieland
einen Hof übernehmen.
Neben Milchwirtschaft
betreiben sie einen Hofladen
mit Frischprodukten und betreuen
Menschen mit Beeinträchtigung.
Gut, wir gehen jetzt mit diesen
Kisten rüber ins Bienenhaus.
Wir räumen sie dort ein.
Das machen wir
sorgfältig, langsam und leise,
denn die Bienen
sind ja jetzt in der Winterstarre.
Jawohl.
Das Bienenhaus
sieht schon super aus, oder?
Ja, es ist wunderschön geworden.
Gut, haben wir es hierher versetzt.
- Ja.
Die Sonne scheint ideal drauf.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt,
leise arbeiten hier drin.
Jawohl.
So.
Gemeinsam mit Peter und Andreas rich-
tet Thom das Bienenhaus fertig ein.
Sehr gut. Alles hat Platz hier drin.
Tipptopp.
Jetzt noch die Deckel. Super.
Die sind sauber gewaschen. Sehr gut.
So, jetzt wollen wir sie
nicht mehr stören. Gehen wir raus!
Von draussen schauen wir,
ob sie noch etwas fliegen,
wenn die Sonne scheint.
Ja, wunderbar,
wie die Sonne draufscheint.
Der nächste Schritt ist,
sich einzuarbeiten.
Mit dem Melken,
der Futterzubereitung, dem Wald.
Das kommt eins ums andere.
Wir sind sicher realistisch.
Es wird viel zu tun sein.
Aber ich denke, wir sind gut vorbe-
reitet, wissen, was auf uns zukommt.
Das ist nicht nur so eine Laune -
mal sehen, was auf dem Land geht.
Wir kennen das und sind voller
Tatendrang für die Umsetzung.
Bzw. wir stecken mittendrin.
Familie Wieland betrieb schon früher
einen Hof mit Agrotourismus.
Damals mieteten sie noch.
Das ist jetzt anders.
Salome und Thom sind die Besitzer.
Darum muss alles vorwärts gehen.
Neben Milchbetrieb und Hofladen
wollen sie Hochzeitsapéros, Events
und später Bed and Breakfast
anbieten.
Nur so kommen sie
auch finanziell über die Runden.
Wir haben hier
schon diese Wand herausgerissen.
Wir fanden, es wäre cool,
hier etwas Licht hineinzubringen,
Weite zu schaffen.
Hier im Wohnzimmer
ist schon einiges passiert.
Hier möchte ich noch eine schöne
Lampe mit Schirmchen anbringen,
die dann so hängen,
wie im Wohnzimmer.
Natürlich in Weiss.
Die Vorhänge übernahmen wir
von Ernst und Lydia, die sind cool.
Im Büro hat sich während des Umzugs
einiges angesammelt.
Weil ich das Einrichten
priorisierte.
Im Büro
gibt es noch viel abzuarbeiten.
Den Ramsch, der hier liegt,
müsste ich aufarbeiten.
Das sind halt die Sachen,
die im Büro so anfallen.
Ja, krass, wenn ich so rausschaue:
Hier entsteht dann
die geplante, grosse Terrasse.
Mal sehen, wie das dann aussieht.
* Eindringliche Orgelmusik *
Hört jetzt die berühmte Geschichte
von Adam und Eva
aus einer neuen Bibelübersetzung.
Z.B. eben dass der erste Mensch in
der biblischen Geschichte kein Mann,
sondern ein geschlechtloses
oder modern gesagt
ein intersexuelles Wesen war.
Adam kommt von Adama,
was Erde heisst,
am besten übersetzt mit Erdling.
Die Geschichte in der Bibel
erzählt also,
dass Gott diesen Erdling
in einen wunderschönen Garten setzt,
ins Paradies.
Aber dort merkt Gott bald:
"Es ist nicht gut,
dass der Mensch allein ist."
Und da halbiert Gott Adam,
nimmt die eine Hälfte
des Adam-Wesens
und formt eine Frau daraus.
Durch diesen grossen Eingriff wird
der Erdling Adam auch verändert.
Er erwacht dann als Mann.
Man könnte also sagen:
Zuerst war dieser Erdling
und dann wurden Frau und Mann
gleichzeitig erschaffen.
Auch wenn das
natürlich nie so passiert ist,
ist es doch eine
sehr wirkmächtige Geschichte
für das Verhältnis
von Frau und Mann.
Wenn man es so liest,
ist für mich auch klar,
dass es da nicht nur um Beziehungen
zwischen Männern und Frauen geht.
Geschweige denn
dass andere Paarformen,
wie zwei Frauen miteinander
oder zwei Männer,
irgendwie nicht gut wären.
"Es ist nicht gut,
wenn der Mensch alleine ist."
Amen.
* Gemütliche Akkordeonklänge *
Dann nehme ich die Stangen
und du rollst.
Über 30 Jahre haben Lydia und Ernst
ihren Hof bewirtschaftet,
bevor sie ihn
an die Familie Wieland verkauften.
Ich muss schon vorangehen.
Aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
mussten sie den Betrieb aufgeben.
Lassen wir diese Sonnenblume
für die Vögel stehen?
Die können die noch fressen.
Es gibt noch dieses und jenes.
Aber die Zäune hier zu entfernen,
ist wahrscheinlich das Letzte.
Der hier ist etwas angefroren.
Jetzt wohnen sie im Nebenhaus
und unterstützen ihre Nachfolger
am Anfang noch.
Ist das das Letzte?
Ja, hier kommt noch der Abschluss-
pfosten, den habe ich abgenommen.
Vielleicht ein bisschen helfen.
Aber äh ... Das sehen wir dann.
Ich denke, du wirst schon noch
helfen. Zeigst ihnen wie, was, wo.
Aber ich bin froh, dass ich nicht
mehr alles alleine machen muss.
Ich denke, dass wir uns vielleicht
auf bestimmte Tage oder Halbtage
einigen werden.
Ich möchte
nicht ständig hier sein müssen,
weil ich vielleicht helfen muss.
Ich möchte vielleicht
auch noch etwas anderes machen.
Und wir wollen sie
auch machen lassen.
Und uns darüber freuen,
wie sie es machen.
Das habe ich mir
jedenfalls vorgenommen.
Ja.
Ich will nicht wie im Gotthelf-Film
hinter dem Vorhang hervorgucken.
Ja.
Doch, doch.
Holen wir den noch.
Nicht zu schnell.
* Stimmengewirr,
verhallender Chorgesang *
Wiedersehen.
- Adieu, danke fürs Kommen.
Gut gemacht.
Salut, Aline.
Mutig, mutig. Mir gefiel's.
Ich fragte mich schon, ob es
zu mutig sei. Aber ich wagte es.
Sehr mutig. Mir hat's gefallen.
Frau Berger.
- Herr Jäggi.
Vielen Dank. Jetzt wissen sie,
wo Barthel den Most holt.
Ich fand das ziemlich mutig von dir,
dich einfach mal hinzustellen
und zu sagen: Für mich ist es so.
Ich kann mir das gut anhören.
Und ...
... was die Stammgemeinde
dazu meint ...
Das werde ich gleich hören.
- Genau.
Hallo.
Ich wäre beinahe zu spät gewesen.
(Matthias Jäggi)
Du hast es fast nicht geschafft?
Bei Hausarzt Martin Sigg in Hergiswil
hat sich einiges getan.
Nach dreijähriger Suche hat er einen
potenziellen Nachfolger gefunden.
In den letzten Wochen stellte sich
ein Kandidat bei ihm vor,
der seine Praxis übernehmen
und in den Räumlichkeiten
eine neue Existenz aufbauen wird.
Die Gemeinde
hat eine andere Vorstellung.
Sie unterstützt Pläne,
dass direkt neben Martin Siggs Praxis
das neue Dorfzentrum Wylpark
entsteht.
Eine moderne Anlage
mit einem Gesundheitszentrum
und einer Grosspraxis mit mehreren
Ärzten, die zusammenarbeiten.
Das Projekt wird aber
erst in zwei Jahren fertig sein.
Und das hat grossen Einfluss
auf Martin Siggs Nachfolgersuche.
Er arbeitet zuerst in meiner Praxis
und müsste das danach planen.
Das Ziel ist,
dass sie später da rüber ziehen.
Das ist eigentlich
noch der Knackpunkt im Moment.
Martin Sigg glaubte anfangs
auch an diese Idee.
Er hatte mit der Gemeinde einen
Letter of Intent unterzeichnet,
der festlegt, dass sein Nachfolger
seine Praxis im Zentrum Wylpark
weiterführen
und die Gruppenpraxis aufbauen soll.
Doch es zeigte sich,
dass niemand dieses unternehmerische
Risiko eingehen will.
Heute findet in der Gemeinde eine
weitere Sitzung statt: wie weiter?
Im Kirchgemeindehaus Ostermundigen
stellt sich Aline ihren Schäfchen.
Es war mutig, ja. - Mutig.
Und bis auf zwei Sätze auch gut.
Ja, okay. Gut, dann machen wir
mal ... Wollen Sie mich anrufen?
Ich rufe Sie an.
- Sehr gut. Das geht ins Büro.
Schön.
- Gut. Danke.
Ein guter Anfang.
- Danke.
Ich gehöre z.B. eher zu den ...
Fundamentalen, wie man sagt.
Ah.
Darum gibt es da einiges,
das ich zu Beginn verdauen muss.
Aber ich finde es interessant
zu diskutieren.
Und ich bin sonst sehr offen dafür,
mir auch anderes anzuhören.
Oder ähm ...
Ja, ich denke auch mal darüber nach,
wie das jetzt ist,
was Sie heute Morgen gesagt haben.
Vielleicht muss ich mich da
noch mehr öffnen oder ... Ja.
Doch.
- Gut.
Alles Gute.
- Wie war noch Ihr Name?
Rahel Wagner.
- Freut mich.
Dann auf ein andermal.
Das wäre schön.
Ja, sicher. Auf Wiedersehen.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich Herr Wagner.
- Sie sagen es.
Auf Wiedersehen. Schönen Sonntag.
- Machen Sie's gut. Es war gut.
Kommst du mittratschen?
- Ja, wenn ich darf.
Ja. Also ...
Danke für die Musik. Das war super.
Konnte man mir zuhören?
- Man hat sehr gerne zugehört.
Wirklich. Du hast den Mut, die Dinge
einfach auf den Tisch zu legen.
Mit Nachdruck,
aber mit so einer guten Art,
dass man es dir
einfach auch abkauft.
Ich fühlte mich wohl, hörte gerne zu
und musste manchmal schmunzeln.
Ah, ich hatte
auf etwas Lachen gehofft.
Und ehrlich gesagt, so ...
Ähm, du hast mir auch noch
Nachhilfeunterricht
in theologischer Arbeit, in Bezug
auf diese Hälftigkeit gegeben.
Das fand ich so gut.
Es war ein überzeugender Start.
- Es war toll.
* Sanftes Glockenspiel *
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Familie Wieland
erlebt einen turbulenten Start
in ihre Selbstständigkeit.
Das Sturmtief Burglind hat gewütet
und die Bäume in ihrem Wald
gleich reihenweise geknickt.
70 m3 Wald sind verloren gegangen.
Neben dem Aufbau ihres Betriebs
heisst's jetzt: aufräumen.
Magst du die einzelnen Äste auf
einen Haufen werfen, Peter? - Ja.
Dann können wir die mit dem Kran
zum Schnitzelhaufen bringen.
Bevor sie den Hof übernahmen,
hat Thom nebenher noch gearbeitet
und hatte so ein Grundeinkommen.
Vorher war ich Arbeitnehmer
und jetzt sozusagen Arbeitgeber
bzw. Unternehmer.
Da hat man einfach
viel mehr Selbstverantwortung -
noch mehr als vorher.
Man ist auf sich selber gestellt.
Man sieht auch, wie sehr man
von der Natur abhängig ist.
Man ist stark abhängig,
wie wir mit dem Sturm gesehen haben.
Z.T. ist man machtlos.
Man ist ...
Die Existenz
ist z.T. auch davon abhängig.
Man merkt, wie schnell so etwas
Einfluss auf das Ganze hat.
* Sanftes Glockenspiel *
Während Thom
den Bauernbetrieb betreut,
ist Salome für den Umbau des Hauses
und den Aufbau des Agrotourismus
zuständig.
Es ist schon speziell,
wenn man einen eigenen Hof hat.
Die Verantwortung einerseits.
Und doch konnte man
es fast nicht glauben.
Noch jetzt frage ich mich manchmal,
ob das wirklich unseres ist.
Es ist aber sehr cool.
Ein cooles Gefühl.
Man macht die Dinge
dann auch nicht für jemand anderen,
sondern für das Eigentum.
Salome managt auch Andreas'
und Peters Tagesstruktur,
die fest zur Familie gehören.
Neu ist auch, dass Thom immer da ist.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut.
Es ist schön, dass Thom
mittags zum Essen hier ist.
Und doch
hat man nicht viel voneinander.
Beim Mittagessen schon. Aber sonst
ist er den ganzen Tag weg.
Wir sehen uns
gar nicht viel öfter als zuvor.
Ich stellte mir vor, das wäre
anders. Aber so war es nicht.
Ausser wenn ich im Stall helfe.
Oder wenn wir Arbeiten zusammen
erledigen, z.B. Äste sammeln.
Dann sehen wir uns.
Aber wenn jeder seine Arbeit hat
und der nachgeht,
dann sehen wir uns
wirklich nicht so oft.
In einer ersten Phase sollen Events
wie Hochzeitsapéros
und Sonntagsbrunches
eine Haupteinnahmequelle sein.
Darum treiben sie den Umbau
einer neuen Terrasse voran.
Wird das gut bei euch?
- Ja.
Sehr gut.
Konntet ihr
bereits alle Röhren verschliessen?
Ja, wir decken die Röhren jetzt ab
und planieren dann.
Dann können wir
mit dem Kies den Aufbau machen.
Sehr gut. Es sieht super aus.
Die Schwelle dort, damit das Wasser
ablaufen kann, ist super.
Damit das Wasser
nicht mehr in den Keller läuft, ja.
Wunderbar, super. Danke! Bis
zum Mittag, ca. 12 Uhr. Ist gut?
(Beide) Ist gut. Vielen Dank.
- Bis nachher.
Hier entsteht eben die Terrasse.
Das wäre die erste Ebene.
Über eine Treppe
geht es auf die zweite Ebene.
Und dann hier runter
auf die dritte Ebene.
Da drüben vor dem Bäumchen
ist ein Speicher geplant.
In Hergiswil
findet die entscheidende Sitzung
über die Nachfolge des Hausarztes
statt.
Dabei sind Vertreter des Kantonsspi-
tals Stans, der Bauherr des Wylparks,
der Gemeindepräsident
und die FMH Services,
die Agentur, die mit der Nachfolger-
suche beauftragt worden ist.
Es geht nicht darum, dass sie
nicht selbstständig sein wollen.
Sie alle wollen sich eben
von einem Konzept befreien.
Sei das im Spital oder in einer
Gruppenpraxis, wo sie jetzt sind.
Aber wenn ich eine Grosspraxis
mit fünf, sechs Ärzten mache:
Wer hat das Sagen? Am Schluss
lande ich wieder im gleichen Kuchen.
Es ist gar nicht besser.
Das war für mich das Ergebnis
der Gespräche mit den Interessenten,
warum die gar nicht
in eine Grosspraxis wollen,
mit der Vorstellung,
dass dort drei, vier Ärzte sind.
Wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe,
haben wir eine Person, Herrn Dr. W.,
der bereit wäre,
deine Praxis zu übernehmen.
Und fertig.
Ja, das ist Fakt.
- (Mehrere) Ja, so haben wir es.
Wir haben den Letter of Intent
mit klarer Stossrichtung
und klaren Zielen:
eine erste Etappe bei dir
und eine zweite im Wylpark.
Ich persönlich will vorläufig
noch daran festhalten
und nicht jetzt schon die Flinte
ins Korn werfen und alles aufgeben.
Ich möchte immer noch
auf dieses Ziel hinarbeiten.
Ich habe einfach Angst, dass der
dann geht und etwas anderes macht.
Wir müssen ehrlicherweise
auch zugeben:
Das Wichtigste am Ganzen ist, dass
wir überhaupt einen Hausarzt haben.
Nicht, dass wir eine Praxis in dem
Sinne haben, sondern den Hausarzt.
Und wo der dann genau ist,
ist dann eher sekundär.
Der nächste Schritt
ist die Praxisübernahme,
der Vertrag zwischen Herrn W.
und Herrn Sigg.
(Frau) Mhm.
So oder so, das machen wir jetzt.
Okay. Vielen Dank für alles. Ciao.
Eine pragmatische Lösung für alle.
Das Abenteuer Nachfolge
scheint für Martin Sigg endlich
in die richtige Richtung zu gehen.
* Sanfte Jazzmelodie *
Und das ist er:
sein potenzieller Nachfolger.
Dr. Marcelo Walker, Facharzt
für allgemeine innere Medizin.
Er kommt aus Deutschland, kennt die
Schweiz aber aus seinen Ausbildungen
und ist seit zwei Jahren
als Hausarzt in einer Gruppenpraxis
in Kriens angestellt.
Guten Tag, Frau Hunziker.
- Frau Hunziker, hallo.
Dr. Walker macht die Visite.
Grüezi wohl, Frau Hunziker.
- Freut mich.
Freut mich auch, dass wir uns
jetzt noch einmal sehen können.
Wie geht's Ihnen
gesundheitlich aktuell?
Es geht, danke.
Ja. Sie halten sich
ja sehr gut mit Ihrem Alter.
Ja.
- Sie sind über 90.
92.
- Ja, schön.
Schon recht viel.
- Ja, super. Schön.
Auch Sie hatten eine Bronchitis,
wie so viele in der Grippezeit.
Sie brauchten ja sogar Antibiotika.
Das ist ja
eher nicht so häufig bei Viren.
Aber Sie hatten Fieber und Auswurf.
Das war dann doch gut,
dass wir das so machten.
Ja, jetzt geht es mir
einigermassen gut.
Ja. Schön.
- Das habe ich Ihnen zu verdanken.
Danke.
Er ist ein guter Doktor,
er lacht immer.
Er ist nie traurig.
- Ja, stimmt.
Er kann die Patienten auf... äh ...
Wie sagt man?
Aufmuntern? Ja? Schön.
- Ja.
Schön. Okay, Frau Hunziker.
Alles Gute.
Es hat mich sehr gefreut.
Bleiben Sie gesund.
Sie auch.
- Bleiben Sie so, wie Sie sind.
Ja. Sie aber auch, Frau Hunziker.
Es war immer sehr angenehm.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Marcelo Walker spielte
schon länger mit dem Gedanken,
sich selbstständig zu machen.
Ich fragte mich
natürlich von Anfang an,
ob ich das überhaupt wagen,
das Risiko auf mich nehmen soll.
Und was ist,
wenn es dann nicht gut kommt?
Aber wie man so schön sagt:
Wer nicht wagt, der nicht gewinnt.
Deswegen überlegte ich mir:
"Ich muss das Abenteuer wagen."
Das Risiko ist überschaubar.
Von daher denke ich,
dass ich das Richtige mache, ja.
Die Lage Hergiswils, Martin Sigg
und sein Umgang mit den Patienten
haben den Ausschlag gegeben.
Er kann so eine gut laufende Praxis
mit einem Stamm
von über 5'000 Patienten übernehmen.
Es wird
eine grosse Herausforderung sein,
in die Fussstapfen
eines beliebten Vorgängers zu treten.
Ich glaube,
die sind tatsächlich recht gross.
Ich habe jetzt von Kollegen
einiges über ihn gehört.
Er ist ja schon seit Jahrzehnten
in Hergiswil.
Er ist da eine richtige Instanz.
Davor habe ich tatsächlich Respekt.
Er war über 35 Jahre da tätig,
hat sich einen guten Ruf aufgebaut.
Er nahm sich Zeit mit den Patienten,
sprach mit ihnen.
So hat er sie über Jahre
immer wieder
qualitativ hochwertig behandelt.
Ich glaube, da kommen
grosse Fussstapfen auf mich zu,
in die ich gerne trete.
Aber ich denke,
das wird alles machbar sein.
* Piepsende Telefontasten *
Irgendwann ist es Zeit, loszulassen.
Zeit für einen Neuanfang.
Es ist ein festlicher Stil.
Es sind spezielle Hemden,
die es sonst nicht gibt.
Beim Pfarrer, den Bauern und dem Arzt
hat es geklappt.
Sie haben ihren Nachfolger gefunden.
Auch Markus Hauser,
Hemdenpionier aus Bern,
möchte eigentlich bald loslassen.
Ist das zu gross? Zu klein?
Das ist small.
- Meinst du? Ach, ja.
Gut, okay.
- Danke.
Er ist immer noch auf der Suche nach
einem Nachfolger für sein ComeBack.
Einer war drei-, viermal hier
und kam auch einmal
mit seinem Schwiegervater,
einem Bücherexperten.
Sie haben das geprüft.
Er hätte eigentlich Interesse gehabt
bzw. hat er immer noch. Aber ...
Es ist ihm finanziell
im Moment nicht möglich.
Bzw. es ist ihm zu teuer.
Den Preis von 300'000 Fr.
inkl. Beratung, festem Kundenstamm
und Kontakten
wollte er bisher nicht senken.
Möchten Sie eine Geschenktüte?
Besondere Hemden für eine besondere
Kundschaft mit persönlicher Beratung.
Markus ist überzeugt, dass
sein Geschäft eine Marktlücke füllt.
Gut, danke. Schönen Tag.
- Ebenfalls. Auf Wiedersehen.
Gerade in einer Zeit,
in der alles immer schnelllebiger
und unpersönlicher wird.
Vor 24 Jahren,
als er das ComeBack eröffnete,
war er mit seinem Hemdengeschäft
ein Pionier.
Inzwischen ist auch der Handel
mit Massenware aus dem Internet
und dem Grosshandel
immer stärker geworden.
Mit 72 will er jetzt
in Pension gehen.
V.a., um mehr Zeit mit einer Freundin
verbringen zu können.
Das ist wirklich der Hammer.
Markus bleibt sehr ruhig.
Er ist nicht ... Höchstens
hinter dem Steuer, sonst nicht.
Aber sonst wirklich nicht.
Sonst ist er die Ruhe selbst.
Ich habe keine speziellen
Veränderungen an ihm wahrgenommen.
* Dumpfe Melodie *
Und das
passiert in der nächsten Folge:
Markus macht sich Gedanken
zu seiner Kundschaft.
Sie kommen ganz sicher
an erster Stelle wegen der Hemden.
Und dann vielleicht noch
ein bisschen wegen mir, aber ...
Hergiswil
bekommt einen neuen Hausarzt.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
Also, nun habt ihr
diesen Film gesehen.
Aline behandelt mit ihren Schülern
das Thema Flucht.
... wie schlimm das ist und wie gut
es uns geht. Man sollte helfen.
Möchten Sie sich einhaken?
Ja, ist gut.
- Ja.
Peter Christen hat eine neue Aufgabe.
Und Familie Wieland hat ihre erste
Hochzeit auf dem Hof mit 150 Gästen.
Das und mehr in der nächsten Folge
von "Abenteuer Nachfolge".